Dave Ramsey doesn't give very
sophisticated advice you know what
that's true I don't I teach you to do
really really really easy to understand
but profound life-changing things to do
like live on less than you make no one
does it those that do become wealthy
those that do are in a position to be
generous those that do avoid debt those
that don't are a victim of society it's
all stacked against the little man he
can't get ahead we're right live on less
than you make get out of that because if
you don't have payments you have money
the problem is not that most of you
don't earn a decent living most of you
give it to other people because you
couldn't resist buying crap they you
didn't have the money for you buy stuff
that you don't really need with money
you don't have to impress people that
you don't even really like and you give
them all your money thus they're
building in the skyline and the
furniture and their executive officers
is way nicer than your double-wide you
gave them all your money you work your
fingers to the bone and all you gots
bony fingers remember the old song now
some of you ain't that old okay anyway
that's the deal live on less than you
make it out of debt always be giving
money away be a good tipper even when
the server isn't good you don't really
say anything about the other people when
you don't leave a tip you say more about
your
well I think they aren't it see what I
mean there you go
you're just an angry backward person and
you're all worried about whether some
little girl bringing your hamburger did
a good job and you don't even work while
you're at work so shut up you say take
it easy and you mean it and then you
don't leave somebody till I'd be ashamed
and the worst ones are my fellow
Christians servers don't even want to
work on the Sundays because Christians
are notoriously cheap they don't leave a
tip and don't blame it on Dave Ramsey
because Dave Ramsey never told you not
the tip ever you ought to give if you
ought to find somebody that's having a
bad day and hand them 20 bucks 100 bucks
a thousand bucks
you'd have to have the money to be able
to do that so you'd have to be doing the
other thing which is like living on a
budget a written plan no one gets to
their destination if they don't know
what the destination is most people with
their money do ready fire aim the proper
way to do it will be ready aim fire
you're gonna go to Florida you can make
up your route from wherever you are
along the way or you could just go ahead
and map out where Florida is and start
heading in the proper direction you'd
have to however know where Florida is
otherwise you wouldn't be getting there
you'd have to go by proven principles
like which ways north in which way south
I don't like absolute truth I I get it
but you're just stupid because there is
absolute truth that ways north that way
south and it's independent of your
little pointed head there are things
that are the absolute truth one plus one
equals two and you can't get creative
about that Florida is that way Canada is
the other way and if you don't like that
you're just what's known as wrong that's
all it's pretty simple y'all so you
gotta have a plan you're going to get
where you're going only if you know
where you're going
and you take the steps to get there
that's a budget of unless than you make
live on a budget don't get into debt
be generous see this stuff's not hard oh
by the way then you could save couldn't
you if you saved a hundred dollars a
month in a decent growth stock mutual
fund from age 25 to age 65 you'd have 1
million one hundred seventy six thousand
dollars I don't like your interest rate
assumptions okay so change them that's
not the point stupid the point is you
won't have any money if you don't save
some money it's a basic concept you want
money in your savings account you want
to retire with dignity it's not an
accident no one gets to millionaire
status at age 65 and they look down
there's 1.2 or 2.2 million dollars in
their 401ks and go how'd that happen
where do I go from no one is shocked
they know exactly how they did it it was
over the last 25 or 30 years they put a
little bit every paycheck automatically
drafted out of their paycheck and their
401 K took the company match they did a
Roth 401k or a Roth IRA with a with a
smart Wester Pro and they did it over a
long period of time and this is how you
win this is how you win so yeah the
stuff we teach is really basic here's
the problem some of the most profound
life-changing things you will ever learn
in your life are very easy to understand
love your neighbor as yourself yeah but
he's a jerk I know but love your
neighbor as yourself I know but he's a
Republican he's a Democrat he's a
Methodist whatever you can always find
something love your neighbor it's easy
to understand it's just hard to do it
cuz some people are just not very
lovable if you don't believe me just get
on Twitter I think that's where all that
hateful people live now it's sad
it's easy to understand love your
neighbors yourself live on less than you
make always be generous with money
always be saving money stay out of debt
always have a plan
these are easy to understand the problem
is they're hard to do it's a very
profound thing to decide to take control
of your life instead of letting other
people and let circumstances dictate to
you how you live you can control the
variables you can't control all of them
but you can even put yourself in such a
position that big hairy dramatic things
are not so big and hairy and dramatic I
wrecked my car last night because I'm
stupid I turned in front of a woman it
was my fault that's a variable I can't
control because I was stupid you know
what I can control I have the money to
buy the insurance and I did and it fixes
my car and her car and she wasn't hurt
and I wouldn't hurt everybody's gonna be
ok because I controlled the variables I
could control even though I apparently
don't know how to drive so there you go
and then a car wreck years decades
stupid but you know what those are
variables you can't control I actually
could control that variable my wife told
me about it on the way home but anyway
there you go this is the Dave Ramsey
show